Hablemos un poco sobre polímeros cristalinos y
amorfos. En videos anteriores hablamos de sólidos
cristalinos en contraste con sólidos amorfos. Los
sólidos cristalinos tienen un patrón muy regular,
tal vez se vean como algo así. Si imaginamos las
partículas, cada uno de estos círculos podrían
ser un átomo, un ion o una molécula. Mientras que
un sólido amorfo es algo irregular, es un sólido,
por lo que estas partículas no se mueven una al
lado de la otra como lo harían en un líquido,
pero su patrón es irregular, de modo que esto
es un sólido cristalino y esto es un sólido
amorfo en general. Ahora, el enfoque de este
video es hablar sobre sólidos cristalinos y
amorfos hechos de polímeros. En realidad los
polímeros pueden existir en algún lugar del
espectro entre cristalino y amorfo; entonces, a
manera de revisión, ¿qué es un polímero? Bueno,
un polímero es una molécula que se compone
de subunidades repetidas, así que tenemos
una subunidad que está unida a otra y a otra,
y se forman estas moléculas que a una escala
molecular son largas y están compuestas por estas
unidades repetitivas. Y para poder representarlos,
si tuviera que alejarme un poco sería como
una especie de cuerda, pero recuerda que
están formadas por estas unidades repetitivas.
Ahora, en videos anteriores hablamos sobre cómo
los polímeros pueden ser amorfos debido a que
estas largas cadenas de unidades repetitivas
pueden entrelazarse de esta manera y formar una
bola desordenada. Y hablamos sobre cosas como
elastómeros, como el caucho natural, que es como
esto y al que podemos estirar, y mientras no lo
jalemos demasiado volverá a su forma original.
Pero resulta que estos polímeros también pueden
alinearse en varios grados y volverse un poco más
cristalinos. Por ejemplo, incluso con el caucho,
al estirarlo es posible que las cadenas
individuales se alineen un poco más y entonces las
fuerzas intermoleculares entre ellas serán un poco
más fuertes, porque estarán un poco más alineadas,
de modo que esta forma sería más cristalina, no
perfectamente cristalina, pero es más cristalina
al estar alineada de esta manera. Veamos ejemplos
de diferentes polímeros que se pueden encontrar en
el espectro. Déjenme dibujar el espectro por
aquí, donde en este extremo tenemos algo que
es muy amorfo y en este extremo tenemos algo muy
cristalino. Podemos ver ejemplos de nuestra vida
cotidiana. Si nos enfocamos en plásticos, por
ejemplo, el poliestireno que nos es familiar,
ya que se usa como espuma de embalaje -lo tenemos
aquí-, es razonablemente amorfo. No voy a dar
los números exactos, pero digamos que podríamos
ponerlo por aquí. Esto está hecho de polímeros,
unidades repetitivas, pero van a estar bastante
desordenadas, algo así, y eso es lo que le da
su suavidad, por eso es bueno como material
de embalaje, puede absorber sacudidas. Ahora,
si vamos un poco más abajo en el espectro
hacia algo que todavía es amorfo pero tiene una
naturaleza más cristalina, podemos ver casos como
botellas de agua de plástico, a menudo se conocen
como botellas de PET. PET significa tereftalato de
polietileno por sus siglas en inglés. El hecho de
que cualquier cosa como poliestireno, polietileno,
comience con la palabra "poli" es la pista de que
es un polímero. El poliestireno está formado por
una gran cantidad de estirenos en una cadena,
el polietileno está formado por un grupo
de etilenos en una cadena, de modo que los
polietilenos, dependiendo de qué versión estemos
observando, se encuentran en un lugar entre amorfo
y cristalino. Por ejemplo, podrían estar por aquí.
Si investigáramos más al respecto podríamos buscar
el grado de cristalinidad y veríamos números
como 30% o 40% de cristalinidad; si queremos
ver especialmente polímeros plásticos que son
más cristalinos aún podemos mirar el kevlar,
dependiendo del tipo de kevlar podría estar en
algún punto en este rango. Lo voy a poner justo
aquí. El kevlar, por si no saben qué es, se usa
para hacer cosas como chalecos antibalas, así el
grado de cristalinidad entre otras cosas depende
de qué tan alineados estén estos polímeros. En
el kevlar los polímeros están muy, muy alineados
entre ellos, y de ese modo pueden tener fuerzas
intermoleculares razonablemente fuertes, y
es por eso que es capaz de detener balas,
mientras que nunca querrías detener una bala con
espuma de embalaje. Todos estos son polímeros.